♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
IT'S THE END OF IMPEACHMENT
WEEK ONE, THE PUBLIC
HEARINGS BEGAN THIS WEEK IN
WASHINGTON.
DEMOCRATS KICKED OFF THE
SPECTACLE ON WEDNESDAY,
YOU'LL REMEMBER, BY TROTTING
OUT A STATE DEPARTMENT EACH
EXPLAINING HOW DEEPLY
UPSETTING IT HAS BEEN TO
HAVE AN AMERICAN PRESIDENT
CONTROL AMERICA'S FOREIGN
POLICY.
THEY HATE THAT INTERESTINGLY
THOUGH NONE OF THEM HAD SEEN
THE PRESIDENT COMMIT ANY
ACTUAL WRONGDOING.
MUCH THE SAME TODAY.
THE STAR WITNESS WAS THE
FORMER AMBASSADOR TO URK
MARIA YOVANOVITCH DISMISSED
EARLIER THIS YEAR BY THE
PRESIDENT.
TESTIFYING AT IMPEACHMENT
HEARING.
SO THE ONLY QUESTION OBJECT
TABLE WAS AND REMAINS HAS
DONALD TRUMP COMMITTED
CRIMES THAT WOULD JUSTIFY
HIS REMOVAL AS PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES?
AND FAIRLY EARLY ON
YOVANOVITCH STATED
UNEQUIVOCALLY AS FAR AS SHE
KNOWS HE HAS NOT.
>> DO YOU HAVE ANY
INFORMATION REGARDING THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES ACCEPTING ANY BRIBES?
>> NO.
>> DO YOU HAVE ANY
INFORMATION REGARDING ANY
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY THAT THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES HAS BEEN INVOLVED
WITH AT ALL?
>> NO.
>> Tucker: WELL, THREW HAVE
IT.
NO, I HAVE NO EVIDENCE OF
ANY KIND THAT THE PRESIDENT
WAS INVOLVED IN CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY.
THAT WALLS HER ANSWER.
AND IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN THE
LAST THING THAT SHE SHOULD
TODAY.
EVERYTHING AFTER THAT WAS A
WASTE OF OUR TIME IN A
COUNTRY WITH SO MANY
PROBLEMS THAT TIME WASTING
IS A SIN.
AND, YET, MARIA YOVANOVITCH
KEPT GOING AND GOING AND
GOING.
BY THE END THE HEARING
SOUNDED BY THERAPY SESSION
OR EXTENDED MEETING WITH THE
H.R. DEPARTMENT DEFINITION
OF HEALTH.
THE REAL OFFENSE TURNED OUT
TO BE WOUNDING THE SOUL OF A
HIGHLY SENSITIVE AMERICAN
AMBASSADOR.
>> SO JUST LIKE THAT, YOU
HAD TO LEAVE UKRAINE AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE?
>> YES.
>> HOW DID THAT MAKE YOU
FEEL?
>> TERRIBLE, HONESTLY.
I MEAN, AFTER 33 YEARS OF
SERVICE TO OUR COUNTRY, IT
WAS TERRIBLE.
>> Tucker: HOW DID THAT MAKE
YOU FEEL?
THAT WAS A REAL QUESTION.
HOW DID THAT MAKE YOU FEEL?
IF HAD YOU TO CHOOSE A COLOR
TO REPRESENT YOUR EMOTIONAL
STATE RIGHT NOW, WHAT COLOR
WOULD IT BE?
IT WENT ON LIKE THAT FOR
HOURS.
C-SPAN MEETS THE SHRINK'S
OFFICE.
>> WITHOUT UPSETTING YOU TOO
MUCH I WOULD LIKE YOU TO
SHOW YOU THE EXCERPTS FROM
THE CALL AND THE FIRST ONE
WHERE PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS
THAT THE FORMER AMBASSADOR
FROM THE UNITED STATES, THE
WOMAN, WAS BAD NEWS, AND THE
PEOPLE SHE WAS DEALING WITH
IN THE UKRAINE WERE BAD
NEWS.
SO I JUST WANT TO LET YOU
KNOW.
WHAT WAS YOUR REACTION YOU
HEARD THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES REFER TO YOU
AS BAD NEWS?
>> I COULDN'T BELIEVE IT.
I MEAN, AGAIN, SHOCKED,
APPALLED, DEVASTATED, THAT
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES WOULD TALK ABOUT ANY
AMBASSADOR LIKE THAT TO A
FOREIGN HEAD OF STATE AND IT
WAS ME.
I MEAN, I COULDN'T BELIEVE
IT.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
WITHOUT UPSETTING YOU TOO
MUCH.
I WAS SHOCKED, APPALLED,
DEVASTATED THAT SOMEONE
WOULD CRITICIZE ME.
I COULDN'T BELIEVE IT.
NOW, KEEP IN MIND, THIS IS
THE PERSON WE HIRED TO
REPRESENT OUR COUNTRY'S
INTEREST BEFORE A FOREIGN
GOVERNMENT IN ONE OF THE
ROUGHEST REGIONS IN THE
WORLD.
SHOCKED, APPALLED.
PRETTY EMBARRASSING.
IN FACT, IT'S KIND OF SCARY.
WHO IS DOING THE SCREENING
OVER THERE AT THE STATE
DEPARTMENT?
HOW MANY OTHER NEUROTICS
CURRENTLY HOLD AMBASSADOR
RANK?
BEFORE ANYONE COULD ASK THAT
OBVIOUS AND NOT GUILTY VITAL
QUESTION ADAM SCHIFF JUMPED
IN TO RATTLE THE WITNESS
STILL MORE.
>> AS WE SIT HERE TESTIFYING
THE PRESIDENT IS ATTACKING
YOU ON TWITTER.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO GIVE YOU
A CHANCE TO RESPOND.
I WILL READ PART OF ONE OF
HIS TWEETS.
EVERYWHERE MARIA YOVANOVITCH
WENT TURNED BAD.
SHE STARTED OFF IN SOMALIA.
HOW DID THAT GO?
NOW THE PRESIDENT IN
REALTIME IS ATTACKING YOU.
WHAT EFFECT DO YOU THINK
THAT HAS ON OTHER WITNESSES'
WILLINGNESS TO COME FORWARD
AND EXPOSE WRONGDOING?
>> WELL, IT'S VERY
INTIMIDATING.
>> I WANT TO LET YOU KNOW,
AMBASSADOR, THAT SOME OF US
HERE TAKE WITNESS
INTIMIDATION VERY, VERY
SERIOUSLY.
>> Tucker: VERY
INTIMIDATING.
IT'S WITNESS INTIMIDATION.
WITNESS INTIMIDATION.
THAT'S WHAT IT'S CALLED NOW
WHEN SOMEONE CRITICIZES YOUR
JOB PERFORMANCE IN A TWEET.
THE GAL, IT'S JUST
TERRIFYING.
IN THE SAME COUNTRY SOMEONE
MIGHT STEP, IN MAYBE FROM
THE MEDIA, EVEN, TO IDENTIFY
THIS FOR WHAT IT IS, A
GROTESQUE JOKE.
BUT, WASHINGTON IS NO LONGER
SANE, SO, INSTEAD, MSNBC
SPENT ALL DAY PRAISING
YOVANOVITCH AS A HOLLY
VICTIM OF
HOCTIM OF
HOLEIM OF
HOLE H OF
HOLE HOLF
HOLE HOLYVICTIM OF TRUMP'S TERRO
HOLE HOLYVICTIM OF TRUMP'S TERR.
>> THIS IS A WITNESS WHO IS
THERE NOT JUST AS A FACT
WITNESS AS THE WITNESSES ON
TUESDAY BUT AS A VICTIM.
>> IF YOU REALLY WALK IN HER
SHOES, THE COUNTRY SHE HAS
GONE TO, THE LONELINESS.
>> YOVANOVITCH IS SUCH A
SOFT SPEAKER, IT REALLY
DEMANDS THE ATTENTION OF ALL
THESE LAWMAKERS.
>> THEY'RE WORKING AGAINST
THE STRAIGHT ARROW WOMAN, I
SHOULDN'T CALL HER WOMAN
BECAUSE THAT'S THE
PRESIDENT'S LANGUAGE.
THIS STATE DEPARTMENT HERO.
>> THE STATE DEPARTMENT
HISTORICALLY OVER THE LAST
30 YEARS HAS NOT EXACTLY
BEEN WHERE DID YOU TO FIND
ALL THE POWERFUL WOMEN IN
WASHINGTON.
USUALLY IT WAS A LOT OF MEN.
A LOT OF WHITE MEN.
I'M SO PROUD OF HER.
AND EVERY WOMAN IN AMERICA
WHO HAS FOUGHT IN A MALE
DOMINATED CAREER SHOULD
CHEER FOR THIS WOMAN TODAY.
I CAN GET CHOKED UP WHEN I
THINK ABOUT WHAT THIS WOMAN
HAS GIVEN.
>> Tucker: WOW.
DID YOU HEAR THAT, AMERICA?
THE STATE DEPARTMENT IS,
QUOTE, A LOT OF MEN, A LOT
OF WHITE MEN, AND THAT'S THE
WORST KIND OF MEN, ACCORDING
TO ACCREDITED MORON AND
FORMER SENATOR AND NOW OPEN
RACIST CLAIR MCCASKILL.
YOVANOVITCH IS NOTHING LIKE
THOSE HORRIBLE WHITE MEN
MSNBC WOULD LIKE YOU TO
KNOW.
IN FACT, SHE LIVES AT THE
VERY OPPOSITE END OF THE
MORAL SPECTRUM.
AMONG THE SAINTED.
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN GO AND DAY
AND YOUR AVERAGE TEENAGE
SWEDISH CLIMATE ACTIVIST.
THAT SWEET SPOT OF GOODNESS.
YOVANOVITCH IS THE SORT OF
PERSON, IN FACT, OR THEY
TOLD US THIS ON CNN THAT IT
IS, QUOTE, A GIFT TO KNOW.
REMARKABLY POISED,
REMARKABLY CREDIBLE.
DEMOCRATS MAY REGRET NOT
PUTTING HER IN THE WITNESS
CHAIR FIRST.
>> THIS WOMAN HAS ICE IN HER
VEINS.
SHE HAS A SPINE OF STEEL.
SHE LAID OUT, I THOUGHT, IN
BRILLIANT DETAIL WHO SHE
WAS.
THIS WAS, I THOUGHT,
REMARKABLE TESTIMONY.
SHE IS INCREDIBLY
CHARISMATIC.
>> WOW WAS SHE A POWERFUL
WITNESS I'M AN AMERICAN
DREAM.
I WAS APPOINTED BY RONALD
REAGAN.
I HAVE DONE THIS FOR YEARS.
I'M TRYING TO FIGHT THE BAD
GUYS.
>> I COVERED THE WHITE HOUSE
IN THE GEORGE W. BUSH
PRESIDENCY ONE OF THE GIFTS
WHEN YOU MEET THESE PEOPLE
WHEN YOU TRAVEL THE WORLD.
>> IN THIS AGE OF TRUMP, I'M
GENUINELY SHOCKED BY HIS
BEHAVIOR WITH REGARD TO THIS
FOREIGN SERVICE OFFICER OF
THREE DECADES.
TO DISPARAGE HER, TO DEMEAN
HER IN SEXIST OVERTONES
SAYING THE WOMAN OVER THERE.
SHE MADE A MOCKERY OF HIS
DISMISSALS OF THE DEEP
STATE.
IF THIS IS A DEEP STATE, I
BET A LOT OF AMERICANS
LOOKED UP AND SAID YEAH, I
WILL TAKE MORE OF THAT.
>> Tucker: OH, YEAH.
THAT'S RIGHT.
AMERICANS LOVE THE DEEP
STATE.
CAN'T GET ENOUGH.
LES VEST EVEN MORE POWER IN
THE HANDS OF SHADOWING INTEL
OFFICIALS WHO LIE FOR A
LIVING AND WHOSE AGENDAS CAN
EVER BE FULLY KNOWN.
IF YOU SPEND ENOUGH TIME IN
WALMART OR DENNYS YOU WILL
HEAR PEOPLE SAY THAT OUT
LOUD.
AMERICANS ARE SICK OF THIS
DEMOCRACY THING.
YET, AT THE SAME TIME, AS
CNN POINT OUT, AMERICANS
ALSO DESPISE SEXISM.
WHICH, IF YOU WANT A PRECISE
DEFINITION MEANS, ANY
CRITICISM OF A WOMAN WHO IS
CURRENTLY SERVING THE
INTEREST OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
SO ATTACKING, FOR EXAMPLE,
KELLYANNE CONWAY, THAT'S NOT
SEXISM, WHICH IS WHY THEY
WERE ABLE TO DO IT YESTERDAY
ON CNN.
BUT CRITICIZING AMBASSADOR
YOVANOVITCH FOR HER WORK
PRODUCT, THAT IS SEXISM.
GOT IT?
OKAY.
ON TO LESSON NUMBER TWO THAT
WE LEARNED TODAY.
WHAT DONALD TRUMP HAS DONE
IN UKRAINE IS BRIBERY.
NOW HOW EXACTLY IS IT
BRIBERY?
DON'T ASK A DUMB QUESTION
IT.
JUST IS.
IT'S BRIBERY.
LISTEN TO THE GENIUSES
EXPLAIN.
>> IT SEEMS TO ME THAT THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES EITHER COMMITTED
EXTORTION AND BRIBERY OF A
FOREIGN OFFICIAL OR
ATTEMPTED EXTORTION AND
BRIBERY OF A FOREIGN
OFFICIAL.
>> THE DEVASTATING TESTIMONY
CORROBORATED EVIDENCE OF
BRIBERY.
>> SHE IS RIGHT TO USE THAT
WORD.
IT IS BRIBERY.
>> THERE ARE ANY NUMBER OF
POTENTIALLY IMPEACHABLE
OFFENSES INCLUDING BRICIAL.
>> THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WILL
HEAR EVIDENCE OF BRIBERY,
EXTORTION, THE PRESIDENT
USING HIS OFFICE FOR
PERSONAL GAIN.
>> AND THIS IS A VERY STRONG
CASE OF BRIBERY.
>> Tucker: THEY HAVE A NEW
WORD BRIBERY.
A VERY STRONG CASE FOR
BRIBERY.
ACTUALLY, THERE IS NO CASE
FOR BRIBERY, THAT'S WHY THEY
ONLY STARTED USING THE WORD
BRIBERY THIS WEEK AFTER
RUNNING THE WHOLE THROUGH
THROUGH THE FOCUS GROUP AND
FIND OUT BRIBERY SCARIEST
DESCRIPTION OF WHAT THEY
WANT TO FIND.
HOWEVER, THE SPECIFICS DON'T
MATTER.
NONE OF THIS MATTERS.
YOU KNOW EXACTLY WHAT
HAPPENED AND EVERYONE KNOWS,